good afternoon my name is dr. Deon's at
times I'm a master student in health
policy at the Harvard chan School of
Public Health and a Commonwealth Fund
fellow and minority health policy it is
my honor to introduce John Licklider PhD
chairman president and chief executive
officer of eli lilly and company doctor
let Leiter has had a non-traditional
climb to his current position of CEO he
truly learned the pharmaceutical
industry from the ground up he initially
joined Eli Lilly in 1979 as a senior
organic chemist in process research and
development three years later in
nineteen eighty-two he became head of
that department in 1984 he began serving
as director of pharmaceutical product
development for the lily research center
limited in England he later went on to
hold roles in project management
regulatory affairs product development
and operations in 2005 he was named
president and chief operating officer
and joined the board of directors
ultimately in April first 2008 dr. let
Leiter was named CEO of eli lilly and
chairman of the board of directors in
january 2009 dr. lett lighter earned a
bachelor's degree in chemistry from
Xavier University and his master's and
doctoral degrees in organic chemistry
from Harvard University where he was a
national science foundation fellow he
has received honorary doctorates from
multiple universities in the US and
abroad including Marian University in
Indianapolis Indiana and the national
university of ireland dr. let Leiter is
a member of the american chemical
society and business roundtable he
serves on the board of the
pharmaceutical research and
manufacturers of america as chairman of
the US Japan Business Council and of
united way worldwide and on the board of
the life sciences foundation and the
central Indiana corporate partnership he
also serves on the boards of Nike Inc
and ford motor company for all of his
professional accomplishments it is his
insistence to make diversity of his
scientific workforce a priority that
resonated most with me under his
leadership Eli Lilly has shown progress
year after year in diversity initiatives
and climb diversity Inc stop 50 list
before i turned the session over to our
moderator as she's ja
katie lee professor of international
health and director of the Harvard
Global Health Institute please join me
in welcoming dr. John let glider to the
voices and leadership series at the
Harvard th Chan School of Public Health
so John thank you so much for coming boy
that set of responsibilities as was
outline I don't know how we fit this in
but really appreciate but I'm glad we
did so I am too so I'm gonna jump right
in by if you don't mind starting off
with a topic that is very much in the
headlines which is this new law this
very controversial law in Indiana and
what I thought was a very unusual move
by you and the CEOs of other
indiana-based companies to speak out
against it or to at least ask for
clarifications around it for those of
you who have not followed this very
closely the Indiana legislature pass on
the governor signed a bill ostensibly to
defend religious liberty and practice of
religion which I think we all agree with
but but it raised very serious questions
about protections some fundamental
protections for gays and lesbians as
well as other groups I would love it if
you could talk about when confronted
with a difficult issue like this what is
the thought process behind which you
decide you're going to take this on why
and then what's the process that you go
through to put yourself and your company
very much into the public space in
saying we need to make changes through
this law to defend an important group of
email well it's a very good question and
this has been all over the news in fact
it's been in the global news arena the
past a week or so and of course our
company follows this like we would
follow any piece of legislation in our
home state to put in perspective lily
has about thirty eight thousand
employees around the world and about
12,000 working in Indiana I think to
make things more challenging for us
we're sort of the last research-based
pharma com
in sort of Middle America I mean it's
there it's it's more along both coasts
so we have to be very attuned with the
requirement that we be able to recruit
and retain people from all over the
world not just from both coasts to come
to work in Indiana we're interested in
making sure we've a vital interest in
making sure that Indiana remains a
welcoming place a place where
individuals not only would want to come
to work but would want to stay and and
and and and grow and develop as people
and as professionals and and be
important parts of the community we
think that that is the reality of
Indiana but we were concerned with this
legislation that not not for what it
says about religious freedom but for
what it sort of leaves open to question
about whether or not it would affect the
the rights of particularly the gay and
lesbian community of people based on
either sexual orientation or their
gender identity we want that clarified
we want to make sure that that in the
name of protecting religious freedom
we're not introducing something that
would enable those individuals to be
discriminated against it's it's it's
another decision all together to decide
you know when do you sort of put the
company and the company's name behind
this we felt that this was such an
important issue not only for Lily and
you know you could say for our
self-interest but for the interest of
the broader community and obviously
eight of the other largest employers in
in Indiana agreed with us and and/or of
like like mine and that's why we sent
the letter we did yesterday which i
think is on the front of of USA Today
someone someone told me so but you know
you have to weigh these thoughts
carefully Lilly can't weigh in and would
not weigh in on every every issue in the
in the public discourse earlier this
year we weighed in on another local
issue that had to do with early
childhood education because we were so
concerned that unless we got track
in here we just were not going to be
able to generate within the community
the strength and the the the the the
numbers of high school graduates and
people who are really employable in a
high-tech industry like ours years and
years from now so we waited on that as
well and and I think it is as you say
it's a little different than it might
have been in the past when I think large
corporations particularly a company like
Lily you know 139 years in Indiana
viewed as you know large conservative
you know we we might have remained
silent but I think on these two matters
in particular we we had to speak up yeah
so as I saw that decision and I had a
chance to read some of the things you
had written about leadership and I
hoping we can go back to talking about a
story that you described of from the
late 70s I think of Sir John Harvey
Jones who went was the CEO of a major
chemical company in England described
asked to describe the attributes of
leadership I'll let you tell that story
but but then I I'll come back to this
decision and how it fits into well I
always I tell this story a lot even
inside the company we lived in the UK
from 83 to 86 and I remember watching
interview on BBC while we were there of
Sir John Harvey Jones who at that time
was near the end of his tenure as the
CEO of I see I was the big British
chemical conglomerate really on its
knees in the 60s and 70s due to a
variety of factors he was a lifer at the
company he joined him as a chemical
engineer you know he has a very imposing
presence he had its long black hair and
a foo Manchu mustache you kind of look
like Vlad the destroyer you know that he
was he was the CEO of IC I and by that
time sort of legendary in his terms of
his ability to have turned the company
around and a sought-after speaker so I
thought oh I'm going to take notes here
they're talking to John Harvey Jones and
so the interviewer asked him much like
you're asking me you know how would one
of the most important attributes of
leadership and I got my pen and paper
ready and and he said something that I
didn't expect and I probably didn't
understand until some number of years
after that he said that's easy there
it's two things it's courage and
physical stamina I was expect you know
with those would you think
courage and physical stamina but you
know after a little more white hair and
grey hair I've come to realize the guy
but the guy was right and I think that
you know leadership leadership
fundamentally involves you know doing
something that is has a certain degree
of difficulty it me it's there's always
a from to in leadership you're from this
to that and and that degree of
difficulty means that oftentimes you
have to overcome resistance and
overcoming resistance requires a Monica
courage and under any any circumstance I
i believe the position Lily took on the
matter we just talked about will not be
popular with everyone you know you have
to be able to sort of weather that and
Brooke that too to be able to before you
decide to go there okay I think physical
stamina i tend to translate that down
into persistence you know stay to ative
pneus grit determination because there's
many setbacks along along the way you
know lily has has just gone through a
period where we've lost the patents of
patents expired on their four largest
products and all of you know how this
works the generics come in it's a very
efficient process but we just watched
about 10 billion dollars of revenue off
a base of maybe 25 billion melt away
over a several year period that was
challenging enough but we couldn't have
foreseen in 2008 the Affordable Care Act
which fundamentally changes the way much
of Health Care's delivered in this
country we could not have foreseen the
great recession which was just GAD the
storm clouds were just gathering so you
know any journey of leadership always
requires overcoming obstacles and
dealing with adversity and I think
that's where the physical stamina comes
in I think knowing that I had a serious
health condition a few years ago had an
aortic aneurysm and I was hospitalized I
had surgery and I checked out for two
months there was no question in my mind
I wasn't going to try to halfway do the
the CEO job I just turned the reins over
as Kate knows to our CFO he became the
acting CEO and I recuperated I
you know recovered from that surgery
successfully but you know you can't do
the job of a leader without physical
stamina oh so you describe these two
trades and yet one of the things that
you've often talked about is that it's
hard to quantify or described in great
detail what great leadership looks like
because it varies based on context so do
you think these two things are the two
things in your mind I'm suggesting
they're the only two that are constant
and other stuff fairies or I guess how
do you conceptualize leadership in
different context we can imagine
leadership in an academic context in a
in your first job what leadership looks
like may be very different from if
you're leading a fortune 50 or fortune
100 company so can you talk about
leadership in different contexts and
what that might look like sure I think
that I think there certainly is contact
I think leaders in different contexts
you know can be can look leadership can
look different differently I don't think
it's necessarily also hierarchical thing
where you know we expect our president
to be a leader we expect a CEO to be a
leader a department chair to be a leader
okay I think leadership leadership can
can happen at any level I mean I see
within our company lots of examples of
leadership on the part of people at in
entry-level roles and I admire that I
try to point that out when when I see it
I think a constant though I mean I think
courage and physical stem and are sort
of you've got to got to carry those in
your bag with you you know as you go
through this journey I think leaders
fundamentally take a stand about
something or something they're there
they you know are going to stand for
something they're going to be seen as
being supportive of of something that
maybe doesn't exist today but might
exist tomorrow JFK famously took a stand
in 1961 we're going to put a man on the
moon by the end of the decade return
them safely to earth there's always sort
of a goal aspect to leadership I said to
from two earlier but I think leaders
take a stand
they're unmovable from that stand
they're flexible enough to think about
the ways and means of accomplishing the
goal they try to create a big tent so
that there's no leadership without
followership you've got to invite people
in and and convince people at the end of
the day that what you stand for is worth
their support you know if someone said
well in 87 years tomorrow I guess am I
being CEO what you know what would I
stand for from an industry perspective I
think I think most people in the
industry who know me would say I stand
for the continued robust investment in
R&D and a policy environment that
encourages innovation I mean I think
that that's that's what all I've been
talking about for you know so here's the
for us at the school in some ways the
the million-dollar question so can this
be taught can you teach leadership to
people and if yes how do you do that so
it's a nature or nurture question I
think I'm probably more on the end of
the scale you know if it's you say all
leaders are born versus you know all
leaders can be taught to lead I'm
probably more on the end of the spectrum
that the leadership can be can be
learned i think there probably are some
people who are born with certain
attributes that enable them to be seen
as leaders but you know we were talking
earlier persuasiveness is can't be
confused with leadership I mean there's
somebody who'd like in the city some
would like to separate me from my money
who I'm sure is very persuasive okay it
doesn't it doesn't mean that there that
there that their leaders I think on the
other hand my experience has been that
when individuals are given the
opportunity to lead and sometimes it's
forced on you okay and when they have
around them people who can coach and
mentor them and they have role models
and talk more about that I think role
models are very very important many
people can can step up to leadership i
mean when i joined lily is a chemist in
november in 1979 did I really think I
was going to be the CEO of lily I mean I
laughed out loud I mean nothing could
have been further from my mind but I was
given opportunities over time first to
lead a lab then to lead a department
than to lead a division and then I was
given responsibility to lead the
community united way campaign and I mean
you have all these different experiences
and you find you know I can do this and
and I learn more as I go along I learn
you know how to be a better leader as I
go along it wasn't conscious but it it
it for in my case I was fortunate
because it happened and I I believe that
that most people who walk in our door
can can can develop leadership can be
leaders in the course of their their
careers so what's your strategy or your
company's strategy for developing the
next generation of leaders said Lily
well we have first we talked a lot about
about leadership and as I say leadership
does entail some degree of change i mean
if if we're all we were asked to do was
to maintain the status quo all we would
need is good managers we wouldn't need
leaders we need very good managers and
sometimes they are not knocking
management sometimes that status quo
certain aspects that status quo have to
be maintained in a time of change so you
know I think we when someone joins eli
lilly and company they hear about
leadership almost from their earliest
days i mean we have at different levels
opportunities for people to learn more
about leadership to to assess their own
leadership skills to study leadership
but you know we think about seventy
percent of what people learn occurs in
the course of their normal day-to-day
work we think about ten percent happens
in the classroom we think about twenty
percent happens from coaching and
mentoring we call it seventy 2010 model
it's not a lily model but I mean we tend
to believe that that that is probably
the that the best learning lab for any
of us is is our data experiences but you
have to be willing to sit back and
reflect on those experiences yet you
know Churchill once said about one of
his enemies in Parliament you said
occasionally sir so-and-so stumble
across the truth but he quickly collects
himself and goes on as if nothing had
happened and I think we have to be
conscious of when we stumble across the
truth and and and be aware of situations
where we either succeeded as leaders or
failed as a leader and and try to learn
from that but you have to review have to
step back and consciously do that we
encourage our employees to do that as
well great so students in the room
students who are watching who are here
because they want to not only learn a
body of knowledge but want to prepare
themselves for leadership opportunities
that might come along advice at an early
stage of how you do it how you prepare
for it how you if you stumble across
that opportunity don't go along as
though nothing happened yeah I think
that I think that that leadership
opportunities for leadership abound
first of all and I don't think any of us
typically have the opportunity on a
day-to-day basis to take on a what I
call save the world a boilie ocean kind
of leadership job they tend to be in
small in small things you know I I had
leadership responsibilities when I was
in college for volunteer organizations
in fact sometimes volunteer
organizations are almost the best way to
develop your leadership because you have
a lot of responsibility but you don't
have a lot of authority and I think that
you know when you have the position
power people sort of do what you say
because you ask them to do it or add
demand that they do it when you don't
have that you've really got to bring
people along they've got to want to
follow you because they see something
that's very compelling that's in their
interest as well as the organization's
interest so you know I would say to
students practice I mean practice your
leadership and if you're involved in a
student group if you're involved in some
kind of a fundraising campaign if you're
doing something online with a with a
group of friends I mean you know where
the opportunities to to show that that
leadership what is it that you you stand
for and and how is it that that you can
can bring people along with you
communication is
in an essential part of leadership when
i said earlier leadership usually
involves some degree of change it means
that you typically have to overcome
resistance and sometimes it's not hasta
it's not people that are hostile to you
it's just people tend to get comfortable
in in in a in with a certain way of
doing things are a certain way of
thinking about the world to get to to to
move those people you have to you you
have to present a convincing argument
but you have to repeat that about 500
times sometimes so you know as we looked
at this this journey that we've been on
at Lily in the past seven or so years I
described this huge patent cliff you
know I only said about five things the
whole time I mean I found different ways
to package though but you know I
basically and it said we're going to
face this huge patent cliff and you know
we don't have the pipeline ready yet to
launch and replace all that revenue so
we've got to take some actions within
the company to deal with that we had to
downsize parts of the company we had to
cut costs having said that we're going
to keep in robustly investing robust
leonardi we believe we have an early
stage pipeline that will mature we we're
going to do some other things to help
grow our revenue during this period and
we're confident of the outcome and
here's your role in that in that process
and then something about the fact that I
think today there's never been a better
time to do what we're doing given the
maturity of the science the opportunity
we have to make a difference in medicine
so I mean thematically that's basically
all I've talked about for seven years
and and you know and you're talking
about leading you know a huge company
obviously lots of those conversations
have to go take place at lower levels in
the organization but I I think being
articulate being able to communicate
your point of view being seen as someone
who is has integrity and and who is
legitimately who generally cares about
not only the cause or the stand that
they're taking but the views of others I
think these things are all important for
students to think about
shift gears on talk about something you
brought up which is the most important
change in the health care delivery
system the health care system in America
in the last five decades the Affordable
Care Act it came on soon after you took
over how do you see the pharmaceutical
industry navigating the waters over the
next five to ten years I mean beyond
that who knows timelines get speculate
on what's going to happen in 20 years
but just over the next five to ten years
as we move towards larger health
delivery systems more consolidation we
move towards trying to do more
value-based payments more measurement of
quality more IT all of the changes that
are happening the delivery system it's a
different world it's a different world
for you guys how do you see yourself but
also the industry navigating that kind
of more broadly and what are the
allinger's that it poses yeah it's a
very it's a very good question I think
that first of all we supported the
industry supported the Affordable Care
Act because it was difficult for us to
see when we when we believe as we do
that that medicines are an essential
part of preventing disease and treating
disease it's very difficult to see 50 or
60 million people sitting on the
sidelines hoping almost by chance that
their situations then be such that
through emergency care through you know
charity or whatever they're going to get
access to our medicines didn't make any
sense so we need a system where
everybody can access insurance coverage
I mean I think that's you know and we
take a lot of criticism before during
and after that but I maintain we're in
the right place there with respect to
sort of that people ask me a lot well
what's been the impact of the Affordable
Care Act on the industry I think that
the measurable impact has been that
through the fee which is assessed of all
manufacturers based on our sales through
increased Medicaid rebates and through
monies that are allocated help seniors
bridge the Medicare doughnut hole you
know lily has roughly roughly put about
500 million dollars a year or more into
the essentially into the cause
okay I mean it were were we're paying
from the bottom line as it were I think
in terms of you know when the law was
passed people said well this is going to
be a boon for the pharmaceutical
industry that's the only reason these
guys are supporting it's because they're
gonna have a lot more customers you know
I wouldn't say that that there's been a
huge uptick that that I can immediately
assign to the Affordable Care Act I mean
let's face it today more than eighty
percent of prescriptions in this country
are filled with generic drugs so 4 out
of 5 prescriptions somebody's going to
get written is probably going to be with
with a with a generic but having having
said that I think we're in a better
place when people have access to to to
our medicines as well as to generics and
you know I think one of the things we're
concerned about frankly is as we've seen
the these these these individual
insurance policies come out of the
exchanges yes the premiums are low but
in some cases people are getting a rude
awakening that the copay or the
deductible is so high they can't access
the medicines that their doctors are
prescribing well that's not that's not
health insurance i mean that's that's
that's something disguised as health
insurance so we've been quite vocal and
saying a good health policy is one that
enables you to be able to affordably
access the medicines that your doctor
prescribes that's a decision the doctor
makes if someone is getting a branded
product or a generic product well we
have to compete based on the merits of
the of the other products and and we're
obviously you know that's the business
we're in so good so i am going to at
this moment open it up to questions and
answers from the well answers from you
questions from the audience let's
actually we can I can't ask questions
you can you can and and in this audience
we often like to do the question and
answer from the audience but medication
but but we have some microphones and so
if people have questions for John about
leadership in general about lily and its
strategy and how it's been thinking
about navigating some of these difficult
waters wherever just wherever you guys
want to go I'm happy to open it up and
see what questions are percolating out
there Dean Frank
hi John thank you again for being here
you have those magic three letters after
your name PhD you come from a very
strong academic background got a PhD
here at Harvard a lot of our students
are following that pathway but most
people with those that are continuing in
academic settings you you went into the
world of industry and are now leading
one of the top knowledge-intensive
companies in the world how why are you
reflections about that transition from
the world of science and research to the
way into the world of leading a large
multinational company yeah that's a very
good question the transition for me from
graduate school wasn't terribly abrupt
because I went from working in one lab
bench in Converse hall across the river
to working at another lab bench at Lily
working on projects that use the same
skill set you know we we employ
thousands hundreds or thousands of
thousands of MDS and PhDs in our company
there there's a I won't say it there
it's an academic environment but there
are aspects of that would be
recognizable by anyone in academics we
encourage people to publish papers we
encourage scientific discourse among our
scientists and increasingly reach out to
engage with other scientists in other
companies as well as with academia to to
do our work I will say it was a
transition though from it was a it was a
significant transition to move from the
lab I remember the day I sort of shut
down my lab and you know they they said
I could go back which means I couldn't
go back and I knew it was sort of a
point of no return but in those early
days of being sort of leading groups in
our bully research labs my first several
management jobs I sort of live
vicariously through the scientists I
found I enjoyed it because I could go on
their labs they tell me what they're
doing and so I understood it are you
know to a point today they think I
understand a lot more than I
okay but I I found that it was fun to be
in a position where you could help the
scientists get what they get done what
they wanted to get done so it that that
that really ease that that that
transition and you know we have many
many people in management within our
company who started out as a scientist
as I did not not everyone chooses that
path and we don't force everyone on that
on that path but there there there ways
that I think we've learned to sort of
better help and manage that that
transition for those people let's go
follow up question to that one of the
questions that people often ask about
why is drug development so hard so
expensive what does it take so long I
mean some of it is just it just does
right i mean there's a there's it but
there is another sort of debate that
I've heard and I wondered if if you
could speak to this about how
disciplined is the rd versus how much
creativity and you have a lot of very
smart people who probably wouldn't be
that happy if every morning they shut up
and we're told exactly what to do right
that we'd have a rebellion part of what
makes them excited to go is that they
have a bunch of their own ideas and they
get to play with those ideas and you
want to foster that yeah but you also
want to foster a certain amount of
discipline in y'all focus yeah and that
seems to me to be a tension and people
have wondered aloud whether if the
industry shifted on that in one
direction or another whether it would be
more effective or less effective I
wonder if you could talk about that I I
think we have a pretty open environment
I mean I think that we really leave it
to our scientific leadership to to talk
about the how the details of the how
what we try to do though in recent years
and your questions very topical is to
better define what area is broadly
speaking do we want to work in this is
important when i joined lily in the late
70s we were then like we are now one of
the largest pharma companies but we were
if anybody had an idea doesn't matter
what therapeutic area was in people
tended to pursue those things if it
looked like there was an interesting
lead today we're saying it's really
cancer its diabetes and of course
diabetes gets into cardiovascular
complications a little bit it's it's a
neuro degeneration we have a bleeding
program in Alzheimer's and then we have
some incipient some nascent programs in
pain looking at some new mechanisms for
treating pain and also in immunology
mainly autoimmune disease those really
define the scope of what we're we're
working on and we've recently sort of
realigned parts of our research and
development efforts to better line up
with that and then you can say well
within cancer we can't do everything so
we talk about a cell signaling tumor
microenvironment and immuno oncology
those are the three spaces within cancer
but how we approach those things who we
choose to work with because much of what
we do is in partnership with academic
institutions small biotechs where we cut
a pretty wide swath I don't try to get
involved in in managing that we really
do have to enable our scientists to have
that maintain that balance with the
freedom freedom to operate to think a
little bit sometimes off the track and
and and yet we have as a corporation
have to have a certain discipline to
expect that we have a realistic chance
of getting you know results at the end
of the day recently I've been more Adam
and I guess is the word about sort of
making sure that we're competitive
within these spaces how do I say this
ten or twenty years ago I don't think
there was as much at stake in being
first second or third in a disease
category and sometimes you know you
could be years behind the leader and
still come up with a product that had
its own value and you get reimbursed for
that and all that I'm trying to
encourage our scientists at all levels
to stay much more abreast of what the
competition is doing and it's not always
competition it's science anywhere in a
particular category to make sure that if
we're going to invest there we have a
reasonable chance of being competitive
with with others I think that's in terms
of getting a drug to market and being
safe first second
third this is this is something we're
talking more and more about because i
think the the the marketplace is just
that much less forgiving today got it
Emily partly driven by the shift in the
economics of how yeah I think so now you
know if you come along in your fourth or
fifth but you're better I mean you know
I mean you know lipitor is was the huge
leader in that statin class and it
wasn't the first but you know I think
it's not our product by the way but I
think you know it did so well because it
had certain advantages that physicians
prove that you know felt were
advantageous for many people hi my name
is Rosa I'm at a health policy student
here and my question is on clinical
traded at ax transparency so some of
your competitors GSK and Pfizer for
example are driving this push to open
access to patient level clinical trial
data for the wider medical and research
community my question to you is do you
see this as a threat or an opportunity
to the pharmaceutical community well I
think ultimately it's an opportunity I
mean lily has been at the forefront of
transparency I mean we we were among the
first this is prior to any legislative
action back in two thousand seven I
think we were the first company to
disclose all the non-clinical grants
that we that we made we've several other
things that we've led in disclosure over
the years we're obviously with the
Sunshine Act we we have requirements now
here in the US and soon next year in
Europe for for disclosure I think we can
find the right balance between
disclosing the data and protecting first
of all patient privacy which is
something we have to be concerned about
and then protecting you know information
that may be confidential to the to the
to the company and i think that there's
some there's some good to be done there
i mean i think that you know researchers
having access to two large databases
of a patient yet information I think you
know what you would you would imagine
could be a terrific substrate for
further work and queries and and
planning further research so you know I
think it's inevitable that that you know
the transparency movement within the
industry is has a full head of steam
behind it and I think that you know
Lily's going to to continue to be to be
part of that thank you I am Diane worth
here immunology and infectious diseases
sort of a question may be asking you to
use your pharma organization hat um you
know neglected diseases diseases that
really minimally affect people living in
the US or Europe yet are major health
problems malaria tuberculosis the
neglected parasitic diseases from an
industry standpoint I mean clearly basic
discovery can be done in academia but
the actual production and you know sort
of the development of drugs and the
production really are an industry
function and I just wonder lily is now
moved away from infectious diseases so
you're not directly involved but in your
broader roles um what do you think the
role of industry is what what novel
ideas are there to be able to continue
to discover and then deliver such
therapeutics or vaccines to neglected
populations yeah it's a very good
question i think a partial answer you
know is came from an industry
perspective with the london declaration
a few years ago and i have to give
credit to the gates foundation for
really spearheading that most of our
CEOs meet with Bill Gates once or twice
a year and so he's vitally interested
making sure that you know to the to the
extent possible the foundation works
with us to either incentivize drug
development in some of these areas or to
connect the dots and enable you know
people who may be working in one of
these neglected diseases to at least
have access to her
mystery libraries the one thing lily is
working on we've been very involved with
gates in this TB drug discovery
initiative we're half a dozen or so
there may be eight companies are now
involved essentially they've opened up
our chemical libraries and we're working
with the ad regroup infectious diseases
Research Institute based in Seattle to
to do secondary and tertiary screening
of these molecules in their in their
their TV screen with the goal of having
an oral therapy that can successfully
treat the disease in a one month course
of treatment that's kind of been the the
ambition of this group we have several
of our scientists who are quite involved
in this so even though it's not a
mainstream research effort for Lily
you're correct we essentially ran into a
brick wall in the in the area of
infectious diseases in the early 90s and
we moved our research over to
neuroscience and other areas but we we
still maintain that that that effort and
I think if you look at sanofi you look
at Pfizer you look at a lot of the other
companies particularly the companies are
in vaccines which we are not I think
more and more attention as being as
being paid to this I think the question
becomes how do you sustain that how do
you incentivize it you know how do you
essentially reward the risk takers for
having for having taken the the risk to
begin with but that's great yes
hey there's just I'm sorry one more
thing I wanted to add I do see as I read
the literature just as you do and what's
written in the public space I think more
and more companies are beginning to move
in or you could say back into an
infectious disease and partly because
the FDA you know there's some there are
some incentives there and there may be
others coming in this legislation coming
out of Chairman Upton's committee that
would make that more more enticing but
you know over the years I've heard
people say to me well you guys must have
gotten out of infectious disease because
you know you couldn't make any money on
a seven-day course of treatment you'd
rather be in chronic disease were
treating people for the rest of their
lives I wish we were that clever but
that's not one the thought process at
all Lily wrote the book on a number of
vancomycin erythromycin cephalexin
tobramycin cefaclor all these molecules
came out of work we did in partnership
with others are in our own labs and we
had a 30 or 40 year history of
leadership and affections diseases we
hit the wall I mean I can tell you
personally I mean we we we tried to come
up with what is that the next iteration
on the cephalosporin nucleus you know
how can you do better than vancomycin
and frankly nobody I mean Vanko
discovered in the 50s is still last line
of treatment for for many of these very
difficult to treat organisms so we would
have loved to have done more in that
area we'd still be in there today but
scientifically after after cefaclor in X
in that we had something ha lower carb F
which was a carb assef m it didn't do
very well because it frankly wasn't
better wasn't demonstrable better than
what was already out there so that that
if the science has to get us there and
he turns out these bacterium are pretty
tough little guys they've been around
awhile they they they've evolved so can
I just follow up I'm sorry I cut this go
ahead with a good question is so the the
broader scientific enterprise of our
country primarily funded through NIH has
seen some pretty tough times
that worry you about the about tackling
some of these really difficult issues do
you think I guess you think you still
think the best days are ahead of us on
scientific discovery well I think we've
made a big mistake in terms of how we
have in terms of our funding of the NIH
and we should be funding in at a more
robust way in constant dollars i'm told
the nih phone i h funding peaked in 2003
not last year but 10 more than 10 years
ago Francis Collins makes this point
this is the wrong time not to be
investing in the life sciences we're
starting to make sense of a lot of the
information that sort of began to flow
out of a bigger big pipe when it with
the with the Human Genome Project and
others that followed our our
understanding of dumbness disease
biology's it's exquisite now that
doesn't automatically mean we're going
to get new medicines from that but I
don't think there's ever been a more
opportune time for investment and and
what with the NIH in in my view has done
best is it is to really help elucidate
disease pathways and ultimately targets
if you said to me what's the hardest
part of discovering new medicines
whether it's for Alzheimer's or whether
it's for malaria it's it's it's having
good targets and you know we're not our
industry as spends only a little bit of
what we do we can't afford to spend as
much as we might like to discover new
targets occasionally we do Lily's had a
few over in recent years but what we'd
rather do is is is to is to is that once
a targets elucidated figure it out how
how to make a drug and antibody or a
small molecule that interacts with that
target we've gotten a lot better at
doing that but but the number of new
targets has an increased commensurately
I'm hopeful that it will and i think the
nih plays a big role in funding the
research it really leads to that we need
to we need to increase the level of and
i each funding sorry you waited very
patiently
thing I'm Shelly I'm a student in
biostatistics I think my question
probably pertains to some of the
students in the room I think we probably
find ourselves in similar situations as
when you first started it Eli Lilly in
the sense that we may be know where
we're headed for the next couple years
but maybe we don't have a sense of our
long-term trajectories and I'm just
curious kind of in your career path as
you you know sort of we're given new
responsibilities and had new experiences
how did you sort of manage these like
short-term sort of goes that you had in
very long-term career trajectories
career goes and as you moved along your
career yeah that's a very good question
i get asked that a lot i think that my
advice to people in your position our
people even deciding you know that you
don't know what they want to do in the
short term even i would say follow your
passion life is too short not not to be
not to love your work and I would say
that that's a good place to start I mean
make sure that whatever you decide to do
as soon as you finish your program here
is something you're excited about you
know that makes your socks run up and
down ok and then and I wouldn't get I
I've never really thought I mean I need
a job in 1979 you know we had a young
son it was born at the lying-in or
that's what I still call it so what is
it now the women in Brigham's and and he
and he and I and his mother had a couple
dimes to rub together and I I want to do
chemistry and I needed a job and it was
right after the recession 70s were a
tough time I was told in 1975 you got to
be crazy going to graduate home
chemistry thousands of chemists are
being laid off in this country in the
mid-70s I figured well it's four years
and and I'm you know I got this NSF
grant I can hide out for four years and
hopefully the tide will turn and of
course it did so I would say pursue your
passion do something you're really
interested in the opportunities that you
have today in this world completely I
mean just just just a you know ten times
more hundred times more than the
opportunities that we saw
before us at least or had before us in
1979 so you don't know what's going to
come along and you'll look back in five
or ten years and say well this led to
this and this led this led to that I
wouldn't fret too much about your
long-term career goals you've got a
Harvard a great Harvard education your
your your your bright or you wouldn't be
here you're presumably ambitious and do
something you're you're passionate about
and interested in and and and things
will things will opportunities will open
up I told you I was glass half full okay
or even three-quarters full yeah sorry
quarter's more hands the gym it yeah I
had a quick question about bringing
entrepreneurialship into the domain of
Public Health usually our students are
not very aware of this nor do we as
their professor so do you have any views
on that well I think the great problems
we face the challenges we face in public
health whether it's in this country
around the world demand new approaches
and new thinking and there's great
evidence of that I mean there are there
are lots of interesting exciting things
that are being that are being done Paul
Farmer and Jim Kim came to Lily a dozen
or more years ago and told us that two
of our these older any infected drugs
cycle serene and Caprio myosin which had
been on our priceless since the 50s were
proving particularly useful in treating
MDR TB where they were working in Haiti
we had no idea so we made initially a
donation of medicines but then that
hatched something called the lily mdr-tb
initiative which we launched in 2003
we've invested about two hundred million
dollars in transferring the technology
to make both of these drugs to companies
in China India Russia and South Africa
to enable the creation of markets in
those in those countries for those
medicines and then working with Oh two
dozen healthcare agencies from Doctors
Without Borders to to a harvard medical
school to make sure that health care
workers are trained
on the on the dots therapy approach and
trained to use these medicines so this
was an example of a very entrepreneurial
approach to treating one aspect of one
very difficult to treat disease but
we've seen so many interesting creative
ideas come out of this not driven by us
so much as by our partners and you know
we never would have happened if paul and
jim and not you know knocked on the door
one day and said literally we need to
tell you about this because we need your
help you know we we responded but yeah
you know I mean Paul mate Paul may be
the most entrepreneurial you know
healthcare worker in the world I don't
know but we need new approaches and this
is this is one thing that I've always
thought Harvard could do so well with
the business school the Kennedy School
of Government the Harvard School of
Public Health the medical school my
dream is that that out of Harvard will
come thinking that crosses boundaries
and borders and enables those of you who
know public health to and to enlist
others may be some people who know
business and some people who know one
aspect of medicine or the other some
people that knows policy to really work
together to to make you know to put us
on a different path in terms of dealing
with with some of these problems you
know the old adage is that definition of
insanity you know doing the same thing
over and over again expecting a
different result we talked about that
with in lowly a lot we need new
approaches and we need we need new
thinking and I think to the extent
you're encouraging that through this
program through other things you're
doing here the school's terrific
hi I'm deanza again I'm a nice job with
the introduction thank you very much so
my question is kind of a piggyback some
of the comments that have already been
been made you know you spoke about the
plethora of opportunities available how
you focus on research and development on
needing new ideas so my question is how
much research development do you put
into the communities around you and
bring in homegrown talent and exposing
community's children women maybe two
careers that they don't have exposure to
because I really feel like we are losing
a lot of opportunity and a lot of talent
and people that never get a chance yeah
well without going into great detail we
have a foundation which is our company
sort of our company giving it's not the
Lilly Endowment that's a different
that's the Big Kahuna but the foundation
is the way Lily gets back and we have
narrowed our focus from you know
essentially giving money to many
different organizations across our
community to focusing on science and
math education k to 12 for women and
minority group members in our community
so that that is our focus that is the
major focus of our foundation and we do
lots of things to help accomplish that
internships school-based programs
partnering with others in our community
who are trying to do the same thing
because it's it to me I view it's an
untapped resource it's an untapped
resource and we're trying to do what we
can locally and then in some cases we've
got some national level some work but I
I believe you've got to start at home
and we have a great opportunity in
Annapolis to to make that look different
in the future so we about three minutes
left and I'd love to see if you have any
closing remarks and then I'll just prop
us up yeah I think I'd say three things
one we have talked much about humility
today and I think humility is often is
usually beef it's a leader I think that
leadership is an incredibly humbling
experience I you know the last seven
years for me as loyally CEO there's many
things that we might that I might have
thought we could plan for and navigate
through but there were lots of things
that came along
that failed we had molecules that failed
in the clinic we had other issues we had
to deal with so you know I think that I
look for humility in a leader and I
think humility means that you you have
the courage you're the inner courage to
face reality to recognize you don't have
all the answers to ask others for help
which inevitably need to accomplish your
ends you know I also I talked earlier
about building a coalition I think
leaders try to make the tent as big as
possible I think sometimes in this day
and age where we always be fighting with
each other and you know look at the
Congress and you people take positions
you know taking a stand on something
does it mean that you're completely
inflexible about how you get there or
that you don't take into account how
others see it our others can actually
make what you're trying to do more
powerful so there's a certain openness
humility and openness I think are
important traits of a leader and finally
I'd say I think leadership can get back
to the original point I think you can
learn leadership can be studied I think
all of us around us have people that we
view as leaders I think sometimes it can
be as simple as studying them or looking
at what may ask the question what makes
them effective and what can I learn and
you can read books I mean I the most
extraordinary story of leadership that
i've read recently with 1776 this book
by david mccullough it just tracks
george washington from january first 70
1776 to December 31st 1776 and I never
knew all the and there's a reason why
this guy's called the father of our
country but I I think as you read that
you read that book and you think of
courage and physical stamina and you
think of humility and you think of
persistence all these things resonate
but those stories resonate with Martin
Luther King they resonate with yet you
know with Gandhi they resonate with so
many people so we read about someone
you're interested in and and and you
know i think i think that's that's
important it's helped me that's great
and it's a phenomenal synthesis of
everything you've talked about it last
hour and i'm not going to try to repeat
it but i want to add one more point that
you brought up which i loved which was
the notion of find an opportunity where
you have
lot of responsibility but not a lot of
authority it's really good practice for
leadership I think you probably have
some of that here I love that I I
thought about all the ways in which I
too could get a lot more practice in
leadership John this has been an
exchange I've enjoyed it thank you very
much the time so you thank you
huh